the billionaire attacks never had a
chance of being passed why because
you're not going to tax the rich people
any more than you're going to tax the
other people with all kinds of
cockamania stupid tax law this sounds
really good you have all the politicians
running out with their virtual
pitchforks yelling and screaming screw
the billionaires those horrible horrible
people who have created hundreds of
thousands of jobs and employed millions
of people and literally printed millions
of millionaires in our society they're
so bad we should go after them now you
can argue that there's all kinds of
things that need to change around the
tax law i'd argue that we actually
should simplify it but the specific
issue around taxing the billionaires was
always stupid it's still stupid and in
the future it will be stupid why because
the way that they wanted to do it was
they essentially had two components one
they were going to discriminate against
people simply for being successful and
if you live in a society that condemns
success then you're ultimately going to
lead to demise the whole point of
capitalism is that you can use the
technology and the opportunity and
various tools at your disposal to build
a life of wealth
and happiness and financial security one
of the very very very big
misunderstandings when it comes to
wealth in america eighty percent of
americans inherited zero dollars
33 percent of americans that are
millionaires literally never made more
than 100k the only reason why we're
trying to take more money from the
private sector is because the public
sector is drunk they are spending and
spending and spending and they're
spending money
because it's not their money there's not
a single person in the public sector
that would be spending as much money as
they are
if it was their money instead they're
spending your money they're spending my
money they're spending my brother's
money and they're spending every other
citizen in america's money today the
treasury secretary janet yellen she gave
a couple of quotes and this was a
fantastic article by matthew bellevdeer
from cnbc he laid this out perfectly
janet yellen said we tried to design a
package of revenue raisers that would be
acceptable to members of congress we
paired back on some rate increases that
weren't acceptable to members of the
senate then she went on to say the
razors we have though are appropriate
and they're fair while there isn't mark
to market billionaires tax i think it's
been agreed that individuals earning
high incomes will pay a surtax on their
income tax rates that hits really high
income individuals the only reason why
they are trying to raise taxes is
because they are spending more money
they are trying to spend 1.75 trillion
dollars for what nobody knows they
didn't even read the legislation it has
changed so many times that if you went
right now and you polled every member of
congress and the senate into a room and
you said to them here are all of the
various topics please tell me whether
this is in the bill or not i guarantee
you that they would be confused they
have no clue what is in this stuff
because it is impossible to read
thousands of pages of legislation that
is changing over and over and over and
over again and then to simply continue
to say it's free there's not a person in
the world that is actually being honest
with themselves that says we're going to
spend 1.75 trillion dollars
but it costs zero that's not how math
works that's not how the economy works
and that sure as hell how isn't how
common sense works so we go on and we
look here is what did get passed the
massive spending bill would impose a 15
minimum tax on corporate profits by
large corporations they're going to
adopt a 15 minimal global tax that has
been brokered by janet yellen then
there's a five percent sur tax rate on
individual income above 10 million
dollars oh you're rich just an extra
five percent for no reason
that rate would rise another three
percent on income above 25 million and
then the democrats plan also includes a
one percent surcharge on corporate stock
buybacks now there's a lot of people who
are watching this who are gonna say to
themselves you know what that doesn't
sound too bad fifteen percent minimum
tax fifteen percent global tax five
percent on people making ten million
dollars in income three percent more on
people making 25 million dollars in
income and a one percent surcharge on
corporate stock buybacks guess what let
me let you in the room come come with me
let me pull back the curtain for you
ain't nobody gonna pay more you know why
because there's not a billionaire in the
world that's pulling in income
they don't get paid income
they make their money on capital gains
they hold assets
nobody is getting stroked a 25 million
dollar check as their salary
they'll never see
that 10 more or that 5 surtax or the 3
over 25 million nobody in their right
mind is taking income
they make their money via capital gains
and nobody is touching the capital gains
tax
on top of that the corporations they're
not going to pay more
why
because they don't have profits because
the best companies in our society are
simply taking the profits and they're
reinvesting it if you are a cash machine
and you are actually taking it as
dividends or you're not reinvesting it
it means you have no plan it means you
have no ability to reinvest the capital
to actually grow your business so if you
run a business and you simply sit on the
cash and book high levels of profit it
means that it is unlikely that your
business is going to grow in the future
so that was the knock against company
after company after company tesla
they're not paying more
amazon they're not paying more they
reinvest the profits to ensure that
their business will continue to grow
these are world-class operators that we
are watching play out here and so this
idea that those virtual pitchforks came
out and the politicians we got them we
got them we screwed the billionaires we
got the corporations and they come back
and they yell and scream about how
victorious they are no they didn't
they're simply playing the game because
when the politicians leave office
they're going to go and ask these people
for jobs they're going to go to them
begging them for a job they're going to
go and build lobbying firms it's a
revolving door it's all nonsense it's
both sides of the aisles too it's not
just one side
so if they really wanted to have some
sort of impact they wouldn't say oh
let's tax people that make 25 million
dollars in income i would love for them
to show me one person
who pulls a 25 million dollar salary
that they've been trying to tax hire
nobody gets a 25 million dollar of
income it's all capital gains it's all
asset appreciation
and just as we expected
there's no mark to market they're not
going to tax unrealized gains it's a
stupid idea and anyone that's actually a
proponent of it you should have them go
check in and literally get an
intelligence test on top of that
they're not going to get corporate
profits because it doesn't matter what
they do to the corporate profit rate uh
a tax rate the higher that they put the
rate the more likely it is that there's
not going to be any profits because
companies are going to be financially
incentivized to ensure there are no
profits
so ultimately this was all a waste of
time it's literally a waste of time we
can work as much as we want to continue
to take in more and more revenue into
the federal government we've been doing
it for over a decade now every year they
take in more federal tax income than
ever
but they don't take it from the richest
people in the society they end up
imposing these rules and they drive it
right to the people in the middle of the
economy the rich people spend hundreds
of thousands and millions of dollars a
year
to ensure that their corporations and
their personal lives pay as little tax
as possible you could make the tax rate
90 percent and they're still not going
to pay it
but the people who are below them the
people who are the everyday americans
who start to have any level of success
they're the ones who get decimated by
this they can't afford the lawyers and
the accountants they're not as educated
in terms of how to actually get around
all of these stupid rules that get
placed and use the tax code to their
advantage
and on top of that what you end up
finding is that regardless of whether
they actually pay it or they find a way
not to
the government's gonna spend more money
anyways
and so 1.75 trillion dollars is an
absurd amount of money but we talk about
it like it's literally monopoly money
so then we get to the best part janet
yellen said
i don't think these investments will
drive up inflation at all
comical
first of all they're fully paid for
comical and not by imposing taxes on
anyone earning less than four hundred
thousand dollars comical but by asking
corporations high income individuals to
pay their fair share comical and by
investing in the internal revenue
service so that they can boost
compliance which has fallen to low
levels we have a huge amount of
uncollected tax revenue a tax gap that's
estimated at seven trillion dollars over
a decade
now i'll be the first one to say
that of course if you owe taxes pay them
do the thing that you're supposed to do
but at the same time
if we honestly believe that no one who
earns less than four hundred thousand
dollars a year
is going to have to pay more taxes
then why is it that many of the largest
individuals from a financial standpoint
on wall street they take less than four
hundred thousand dollars salaries
so we're literally saying that multiple
heads of banks
who have less than four hundred thousand
000 salaries aren't gonna get higher
taxes
well what happens when the tech
executives who get paid a dollar or who
take a fifty thousand dollar salary
they also are not going to pay higher
taxes it's the entire point
if you are sitting at home
and you only have income you have to
figure out a way to make money via
capital gains you have to own assets
that is how people get ahead in this
economy and in this environment if you
simply have income they are going to
find every possible way they can to tax
the hell out of it
but they're never going to get the
people who understand owning assets is
how you build wealth not by simply
getting a higher income
now on top of all of this as if it's the
icing on the cake
do you really think if we don't spend
1.75 trillion dollars
inflation will just chill
this is absurd
if you go back to 2020 all we heard
we're gonna spend trillions of dollars
but inflation won't be a problem you
can't print trillions of dollars and you
can't spend trillions of dollars and not
get higher levels of inflation that's
not how it works and so now we sit with
multiple months over five percent
inflation
and they pretend like they never said it
before
are americans really that dumb that we
forget what they said 12 months ago
because it's the exact same thing that
they said last year
don't worry about inflation
it's not gonna happen
well now we're at five percent and now
they're literally knocking on the door
spending another 1.75 trillion dollars
and i don't believe them and neither
does anybody else who understands how
market works